hey guys I'm Lauren welcome to the prep
kitchen I'm going to give you my tips on
how to perfectly braise short ribs the
first thing you want to do is take your
short ribs out of the refrigerator and
bring them to room temperature and you
want to dry them off really well this is
going to help with Browning then you
want to take each piece of meat and
season on all sides with salt and pepper
get your pot really hot on high heat and
then use a neutral oil I'm using a
sunflower and coconut oil blend it has a
really high smoking point when you're
searing you want to work in batches so
that the meat isn't too close together
try not to move your meat at all after
you get it in the pan it will develop a
really nice brown color get them in the
oven at 325 degrees and cook for about
two and a half hours turn off the heat
and let it cool all the way down in its
juices for 30 minutes so my meat has
cooled all the way down and its juices
it's still nice and warm and it's ready
to serve happy cooking